My opinion on the legalization of
marijuana is complicated because when we
think about a society in general,
if we think about these things,
honestly,
every society has.
They're intoxicated,
we have alcohol,
that's our primary,
what we also have to mackle and we have
caffeine which is not as intoxicated.
Now the question becomes,
should we make another intoxicant legal
that we know all the problems that we
have with those with alcohol,
tobacco,
and caffeine,
we know the problems that we may have,
so that means if you have marijuana to
be more widely available,
you can also expect to maybe have some
more problems.
Some of those similar types of problems.
On the one hand,
on the other hand,
in New York City for example,
we're arresting hundreds of thousands of
people every year for marijuana and they
have they as a result,
they have a record or they have some
sort of blemish and that might retard
their ability to make a contribution.
So we are also having some consequences
from our current legal status of the
drug.
So the society has to balance what is
more important to the society,
but they should do so with their eyes
open.
You will have problems either way,
but the point becomes which problems are
we willing to tolerate as a society on
the one hand,
now that's the legalization issue that
you're talking about.
That's more availability.
Now,
when we think about medical marijuana,
um,
the institute on medicine,
did a report,
still tried to study this issue
comprehensively and suggested that we
should probably continue to investigate
therapeutic potential,
the therapeutic potential of marijuana
and that's clearly support that position
that we certainly need to,
if people are suffering and we have
potential medications that will help
relieve their suffering,
absolutely we should go full forth with
that and we should do it in a
responsible way in which,
uh,
in a similar way in which we look at,
in which we use drugs like morphine,
which is essentially heroin.
Um,
we,
we do that responsibly.
Um,
and we certainly do it in a restricted
and controlled manner.
And we should probably do the same with
marijuana.